[Music]
you this is a sign that things are going
really well
none were invited to the White House for
Easter congratulations I was amazing
[Applause]
what you probably don't know is that I
was kicked out of the White House last
Easter oh okay yeah but I was invited
back that's nice inside about you were
invited and that is such a cool thing
did you bring anybody with you did you
bring your family I did you know since I
was here last year I I hooked it up
since this is President Obama's last
year in office I hooked it up so the
entire cast of blackish could come with
their families that's great yeah so
there were 200 people in the picture
line 32 of those people I was
responsible for that's great but I
called my mother and was like mom I'm
going to the White House you want to
come with me to meet the president she
said when I said uh this weekend for
Easter she said oh I don't know baby I
just paid three hundred dollars to play
bingo in Vegas I was like ma it's three
hundred dollars and it's the President
of the United States of America come on
I was like this is probably the first
and the last time we'll have a black
president he wants you to come meet him
he was like I don't know baby you know I
paid for it and the girls are coming
here you know we don't go to DC in
August why don't you hook it up so I can
meet the president in August 6 she
didn't really say that she said me plus
six okay now she did end up going though
right to Vegas yes she blew up
she blew meeting the President to go
play bingo in Vegas and like she's done
for the last 35 years she lost all of
her money okay
she takes she so you're saying she's
taking bingo seriously like your entire
life my entire life I remember my
earliest memory of her going to bingo
was her taking it was four of us I'm the
oldest of four children and she took us
to bingo hole about bingo hall and
Garden Grove and she also took her best
friend and her best friends two children
I'm the oldest of all so I babysat the
cow how old do you think it is I'm 11
years old okay the smallest child is -
yeah my mother parks in an alley next
year - gasps which is like a
we're in winter we're in the truck we
have a 84 Ford courier with a shell on
the back you know plush carpeting seats
in the back you know TV you plug into
the cigarette lighter back up today so
we had that but my mother parked in an
alley next to a Chevron gas station
because she didn't want to park in the
gas station because the gas attendant
would see that they were babies left
alone in the car and called the police
so she parked in an alley so the light
from the gas station could shine on the
vehicle so nobody would come snatches
and you're 11 and you're put in charge
how much 11 how long was she gone PI
maybe three and a half four hours ago
but bingo didn't start till 8:00 so my
mother came out 11:00 11:30 at night
while we were just roaming through the
alleys I had to change diapers I had she
left a snack a bag of snacks in an ice
chest full of water okay yeah that's
what my mama raised me she did a good
job
you turned out get you now pray in spite
of how she raised me up okay
you